you said you'd heard frustration from
voters during the local election
campaign just tell us more what were
they saying to you
hello good evening um yeah all sorts
really I think um summed up by that
frustration around delivery and the
prime minister's talked about his key
priorities for this year particularly a
number of economic priorities NHS uh
small boats and those things came up
obviously on the doorstep the thing I
was particularly raising today was that
leveling up agenda where I know in my
community there's been a huge amount of
government
um commitments in terms of townspend
leveling up fund and other projects uh
our East Midlands Devolution deal and
human authority that's coming forward
but none of it's there yet we've got
lots of things in the pipeline and by
the next election people will expect to
see that bricks and more to the outcomes
of those things it must be frustrating
then to feel that your government isn't
yet delivering for your constituents
we've made some huge strides forward
um not intended to to
um kind of look past some of the really
positive things that we have managed to
achieve Manchester has become a
University Town in the last five years
with Nottingham Trent setting up the
campus on site we've got all sorts of
things as I said in the pipeline
Community Diagnostics Center coming our
way uh capital investment in the college
in the hospital there's some really good
stuff that has happened but in
particular I think one of the most
visible indicators of
um the direction of travel over a town
is its Town Center we've got 17 million
pounds worth of projects from the
government that are still in the
pipeline and still trickling along but
on a macro level
um that East Midlands combined Authority
that we've been working on now for 18
months I need the prime minister to get
the leveling up Bill through in a timely
fashion or that's going to the timeline
for that is gonna slip and that's worth
billions and billions of pounds to our
economy so we need to see that done why
do you think it's taking so long then
well the wheels of government
unfortunately turn uh very slowly I'm a
local Authority leader and it's the same
there at all uh levels I think that we
always want things to move faster than
they do I think some of these projects
because of our complicated structures in
the region
um which again our combined authorities
intended to try and help to tackle but
we've got multiple tiered local
government and all sorts of different
structures involved in decision making I
can go and try and secure funding from
government for things like the leveling
up fund and then I have to hand it over
to my labor District Council who have
yet so far failed to deliver those
outcomes and sometimes just aren't
equipped to be able to manage these
large projects so there is a lot of
trying to hurt the cats to try and get
things done which I've been trying very
hard to do and but the more that
government can drive at that that
delivery point both in terms of the
prime minister's key priorities and for
us the visible outcomes on the ground
those will be absolutely key in the next
election you're obviously a big
supporter of the East Midlands
Devolution deal but that has had its
critics Center for cities has said
um that they're concerned that it's step
backwards because it combines Derbyshire
and Nottingham it says it contains two
separate local economies Derby and
Nottingham in a single structure d2n2 is
not an economic geography and will
potentially create more problems than it
solves I mean isn't isn't this an
example of even more of that bureaucracy
and levels of funding that you were
talking about isn't this going to create
more issues
well if I'm honest I think the incentive
cities are talking nonsense we've had a
d2n2 as the it's called it's called that
because we've had a local Enterprise
partnership working on that geography
for the last
um decade or so so we already work in
that economic footprint It's Not Unusual
but we had originally planned to have
leicestershire involved as well but all
sorts of um issues in leicester's
internal Politics as to why that's not
happened but from our point of view I
see that very much as a way to start to
coordinate our multiple tiers of local
government we all will be forced to sit
around a table and do things together
which we've never done before and we
will have a significant extra investment
for our region in economic development
in transport infrastructure and other
key things to help us drive growth the
biggest challenge we've had in the past
is if you come and talk to the East
Midlands as a private business as an
investor in our region who do you talk
to there isn't an Andy Street and Andy
burn with Ben Houchin to go and see
you've got 18 different councils with 18
different views all competing against
each other so just having that focal
point for our region to draw in
investment will be hugely important I
think what about you'll see to the next
election we've seen the conservatives do
pretty badly in the local elections are
you worried about your seat if this deal
doesn't go through
well I think the the delivery point is
really important my constituents will
expect to see
um some of these outcomes some of them
we've got as I said we've become a
university town and others and some are
still in the pipeline like our new
hospital investment Community Diagnostic
Center like some of the Town Center work
so we've got
um time a little bit of time still to
deliver those but that will be really
really important and in my constituency
um Elite immigration is the biggest
thing that comes across my desk on a
weekly basis so I will be judged
massively on the prime minister's
success in that space as well but our
local elections were all right locally
we gained three seats and although labor
took control of the council their games
came from an independent party that kind
of died to death rather than from us
um I was elected in 2017 when we had no
Castle seats at all so we're in a much
better place than we were then
nationally it was clearly a struggle and
I do think you know the the biggest
thing I heard on the doorstep was you
talk a good game where are the outcomes
if the Prime Minister can deliver those
outcomes then I think we'll win if you
can't we'll struggle